[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCISCO URIBE: The mission
of the computer vision platform
is to enable our partners to
implement the next generation
enterprise AI solutions.
And this focus on the enterprise
has led in the last few years
to significant breakthroughs
of application of AI
across multiple verticals.
Industries are
using our technology
to detect damage
in their facilities
for predictive maintenance.
Media and
entertainment companies
are using our technology to
implement intelligent content
management systems.
And the focus of this talk,
health care organizations
and labs are using
our technology
to analyze medical imagery
to optimize radiology
and pathology workflows.
So a few examples of this.
The brain team has been
using computer vision
to detect diabetic retinopathy
leveraging fundus images
or images from the
back of the eye.
Now this is critical work, and
a significant breakthrough,
because diabetic retinopathy is
one of the leading and fastest
growing causes for blindness.
If this disease is not
being detected on time,
it can lead to
irreversible blindness.
Now the bad news
is that there's not
that many physicians
in the world that can
detect this disease on time.
So it's very critical for
us to empower these doctors
with AI technology so that
we can prevent blindness.
And this is especially true
in underserved populations
where there's not enough
coverage of doctors.
Another example is the
work from our brain team
who has been using computer
vision algorithms on top
of tissues lights to detect
different forms of cancer.
This is also very critical
work because detecting cancer
in these sort of slides can take
multiple hours from physicians
and requires multiple
years of training.
And to explain why, one single
slide is immensely large
and has over one
gigapixel of resolution.
It is also very critical for
us to help those doctors detect
and analyze these images to
improve different patient
outcomes.
Now these two use causes can be
implemented with our computer
vision tuning today, which,
to recap, is comprised
of two sets of products,
our pre-trained products
or the Vision API and
our customizable products
called AutoML Vision.
Our pre-trained products
require no training.
They're completely plug
and play through a code.
You can just simply
issue a REST call
to be able to get
predictions from your data.
These are great for generic
and well understood use cases.
And our AutoML
Vision products can
be customized for
your own data, uses
behind the scenes
[INAUDIBLE] state
of the art neuro-architecture
search and hyperparameter
tuning technology, and is great
for more specialized use cases.
Now last year we
introduced AutoML Vision
for image classification.
And we're very humbled by
the popularity and success
of this tool.
But we know that this is only
part of the toolkit required
to do computer vision,
especially as we tackle
more complex health scenarios.
So for that reason, I'm
very excited to announce
AutoML Vision object detection.
This product allows you to
detect not only the presence,
but the location,
body box coordinates
of objects in your images.
And this whole experience
is very seamless.
And it has the
same model quality
as the rest of the
AutoML product family.
And to explain how to use this
technology in a real use case,
I'm inviting Ben Litchfield,
software development manager
from IDEXX, onstage.
Come on.
BEN LITCHFIELD: Great.
Thank you.
Hi.
My name is Ben Litchfield.
And I've been working at IDEXX
about 13 years developing
software solutions specifically
in the diagnostic imaging
space.
Our mission at
IDEXX is to improve
the health and well-being of
pets, people, and livestock.
What I mean by that is we
sell diagnostic equipment
that detects diseases in pets.
We sell this equipment
to about 20,000
different veterinary
hospitals worldwide.
So if you have a cat
or dog that you've
brought into the veterinary
practice and had a test run,
it's probably been
on our equipment.
We also do testing in
dairy, poultry flocks,
and other livestock animals.
We have an amazing
water business
where our tests are used to
improve the health of drinking
water for 2 and 1/2 billion
people every single day.
Those tests are used on
all seven continents,
in submarines below the sea,
and in the International Space
Station in outer space.
At IDEXX, we love our pets.
And the white cat up
there is my cat, Milla.
So we always try to include
them in our presentations
that we do.
That's a picture
of her hanging out
in our cabin in the
northern Maine woods.
So like I said,
our primary focus
is around veterinary
diagnostic equipment.
And a few years ago, we
started to invest heavily
in machine learning technology
specifically around imaging.
And I want to talk about a few
of these different products
that we have.
The top left is
a SediVue device.
This analyzes raw urine and
takes microscopic images
of the urine.
And then we use machine learning
to detect elements within that.
So that's things like red
blood cells, white blood cells,
and a variety of different
types of crystals
that you can see in urine.
We have 250 million images
from veterinary practices
in our cloud right now.
We're on our fourth major
iteration of our machine
learning model.
The last model we
added the ability
to detect a very
rare crystal that we
had to use machine learning
to analyze our data set
to find data to build up our
training sets to release that.
We have hematology devices.
We also have a
pathology scanner.
This generates about
two petabytes of imagery
every single year
that we can analyze.
We have radiology.
I'll talk a little
about that more later.
We also sell an ECG device.
We bundle that with a
subscription service
for veterinary practices.
This is frequently
used for screenings
before surgeries where a lot
of cases are normal hearts.
They want to know that
the pet's healthy enough
to go under surgery.
So we use technology to
automatically read those.
If it's normal, we'll send
that result automatically back
to the practice.
If it's abnormal, we'll
have a cardiologist read it.
Cardiologists love this feature,
because reading normal ECGs
all day long is very boring.
They want to be able
to focus their efforts
on more interesting cases.
The other device we
sell is a snap kit.
These are kits we
sell for a long time.
And essentially, what
they do is detect diseases
in cats and dogs, things like
Lyme disease or heartworm.
And it's a snap kit because you
put some fluid in there, blood
serum, and then you snap it.
And that result takes a
few minutes to show up.
And it's only valid for so long.
So what we did is we
developed this device,
the snap pro reader, where
the veterinary technician can
put the snap kit in.
It will actually automatically
snap it for them,
set off a timer, and then
take a picture of the window
at the right time.
It reads the dot on
that to see if it's
positive for any of the diseases
and then it automatically
imports that into our systems.
We have a full suite
of radiology equipment.
But we sell both the
capture equipment.
Once you capture an
image, that automatically
goes up to our Web
PACS cloud system.
We have 100 million
radiographs there.
Most veterinary practices
have an X-ray capture machine,
but they don't have a
radiologist on site.
So we also provide
a service where
practices can send
us a radiograph
and we'll have radiologists
read them for them.
And then finally, that
reports and the image
will go back to their
practice management software
automatically.
So I want to drill
in a little bit more
into the telemedicine
workflow, which
is where I see a
lot of opportunity
in machine learning technology.
A typical flow or
typical radiologist
will have a couple of monitors.
On the first monitor, they'll
have their case work list
where they'll have a
list of all their cases
they need to work on that
day, some of the case details,
and then an image view
on monitors two and three
for example.
But one of the things
that they like to do
is they were taught to read
x-rays in a certain order.
So for example, they like to
see their thorax images first,
and their abdomen images next.
So they spend time
the very beginning
organizing all their
data, generally
about 30 seconds for each case.
And right now we're at capacity.
We have several
hundred radiologists.
And the only way we can
really expand our business
is by adding more
radiologists or making
their workflow more efficient.
And we've really
hired almost all
of the veterinary radiologists
there are already.
So one of the challenges
is all of our images
come in somewhat unorganized.
They do have DICOM
tags generally.
But not always.
Sometimes they're also wrong.
In the veterinary practice, the
technicians that capture x-rays
are not always highly trained.
And it can be a real
challenge sometimes
to get a proper x-ray
of a pet on the table.
So they'll come in upside
down, flipped, sometimes
with a title,
sometimes it's blank.
So again, radiology will
spend that 30 seconds or so
on every single case just
organizing their images.
So we spend over half a
million dollars a year
paying radiologists just
to organize their images.
So the obvious solution is to
use machine learning technology
to help them and organize their
data so that when they open up
their case, their data is
all organized automatically
for them.
We started looking at this
maybe last year or so.
And we started looking at whole
image classification first.
So can we take these
images and just bucket them
into high level
pieces of anatomy--
for example skull, thorax,
abdomen, or extremity?
And that works really well.
It was very fast and easy
to sort of train whole image
classification.
We did have a lot of
data that was labeled.
So we kind of just put
those all in folders.
It was very easy to set up
the training and the labeling
of this and build a model.
But one of the
challenges we saw was we
have a variety of images like
this, where it doesn't neatly
fit into any single bucket.
It's not just a skull, or
a thorax, or an abdomen.
It really has
components of all those.
And because again, a lot
of veterinary technicians
aren't highly trained,
they might take images
like this versus sort of
just the focused anatomy.
So this is where the object
detection capability of AutoML
comes in, where
we can now detect
individual pieces
of the anatomy,
and label, and know
where they are.
So with this, I can now take
this image and say well,
the intention of
this was a thorax.
It's what's in the
center of the image.
They weren't intending
to take a skull shot.
It's on the edge of the image.
So our first pass
of this was actually
before object detection
in AutoML was available.
So we hired some temps,
and labeled all this data,
and built tools to do all this.
And in reality, that
cycle is very long.
We built our own labeling tool.
We bundled that together
with some TensorFlow models.
We evaluated that.
We gave that to some
interns to label the data.
And this whole process was
many weeks to months long,
to be honest.
Because by the time you get
that label data, look at it,
analyze it, go look at
which ones were incorrect,
getting good visualization
of what's wrong
and where it's going wrong--
without sort of an
integrated tool like object
detection is a real challenge.
So I want to show
this to you live--
a demo of what we did with
Auto Detection in AutoML.
So the first part that you
do with Auto Detection AutoML
is upload your data set.
I'm going to skip this
part today just for time,
but generally what you do
is just load up your data
into Google Cloud Storage.
You have the ability
to either upload labels
yourself or you can use the
labeling tool within Google
Auto Detection, depending on
if you already have labels
from another system.
So for this example, we
uploaded 15,000 images
and did about nine
different classes.
So the classes are over
here-- abdomen, lateral
or [INAUDIBLE] were at two
different angles, extremity,
pelvis, skull, and whatnot.
This is what the
labeling looks like.
So over here is the skull, the
thorax, cavity, the abdomen,
the pelvis.
And if I want to
add another label,
you just simply draw a box.
And it adds as a
new entry over here.
And you pick what the label is.
So it's really fast and easy
to add labels to your system.
Once you've uploaded
your data and you've
labeled all your images,
the next step is to train.
This does take a few hours.
So I'm not going
to show this live.
But it's pretty simple.
You just hit Train New Model,
and then hit Start Training.
Once your model
has been trained,
then you still need to go
through an evaluation phase
to evaluate it.
What worked?
What didn't work?
Usually I'll do that by
looking at individual classes.
You can look at all
of them together.
But for example, if we look
at skull VDs, what it shows
you first is your
true positives.
And what's really
nice about this
is just the visualization
of this piece integrated
into the tool.
So the green box is what
the model predicted,
and the gray box is what
our ground truth is,
or what our human
labelers labeled that.
It also shows false negatives.
So this is areas where the
model failed to predict
the correct bounding box.
Bounding box detection
is a little bit
different than whole
image classification
because the bounding
box that you labeled
is not going to be exactly
the same as the one the model
predicted pixel for pixel.
So Google and many
other libraries
use what's called
intersection over union,
which is essentially how much
the two boxes overlap for that.
So in this example,
these are ones that it's
saying wasn't really right.
But in reality, it just
didn't overlap enough.
You do have the
ability to come in here
and change that threshold.
So I can lower
that a little bit.
That will raise our accuracy
and sort of change results
down here.
The other thing I'll show
you is the false positives,
so where your human
labeler didn't say there
was something in there, but
the model found something.
And in reality, in
our example, this
is actually cases where the
human labeler missed a label.
And we need to go
fix these labels.
Once you've gone through
a couple of cycles
of labeling and training,
you automatically
get a model deployed.
It comes with some sample
code, which is simply REST API,
or you can use cURL or
Python, whatever language you
want to use.
It also has a really simple
way to test your model
on other data.
So for example, here's uploading
an image and predicting this.
So that was done
sort of on the fly.
So the really nice
part about this
is none of these steps
required any code.
So you don't really need to be
a data scientist or developer
to get a custom trained
model on your own problem
and a model deployed in the
cloud, which is really awesome.
You've taken what
we had before, which
is weeks and months of effort,
lots of development effort,
to something that now maybe a
business analyst could even do.
Can we switch back to slides?
So just to summarize,
AutoML significantly
streamlined our
process for this.
Again, we went from weeks down
to a couple of days to do this.
Our focus is really not
replacing radiologists.
But how can we make
them more efficient?
How can we streamline
their process
and make their work
a little bit easier?
One of the key pieces
I do want to emphasize
is trying to integrate
machine learning models
into their existing workflow.
So as you think about problems
that you want to solve,
what are ones that can be
integrated into your workflow
and not be separate?
If I have to leave the
application that I normally
use and go to someone
else or there's more steps
to be able to
utilize that model,
that might not be a great use
case for machine learning.
And then the other part to this
is this is a simple example
but it has a big impact.
This is going to save
us half a million
dollars every single year and is
a product that now really takes
only a couple of days.
Because of the variety
of imaging equipment
we have at IDEXX, we really
have hundreds of different types
of problems we need to solve.
And AutoML is going to
make that a lot easier
for us to solve these things.
Cool, I am going to hand
it off now back to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCISCO URIBE:
Awesome thanks a lot
Ben for the awesome use case and
our great partnership together.
So now we're going
to have Arie Meir.
He's a product lead for
the Cloud Healthcare Team.
And he's going to give
us the vision of Google
for health care in the Cloud.
ARIE MEIR: Thanks, Francisco.
Thank you, folks.
So I think my colleagues have
presented here how information
is important in health care.
And the value of information
helps make better decisions.
So I want to share a little
story that kind of brought me
into the Cloud Healthcare Team.
So as Francisco mentioned,
I'm a product manager
within Cloud
Healthcare, which is
a team that is in
Google Cloud that's
focusing on industry-specific
cloud capabilities.
And I'll talk a little
bit more specific.
So I happened to move
apartments a couple of times
over the last three years.
And every time I
move an apartment,
I like to find a dentist
that lives where I live.
Like, I just like
that convenience.
And the thing is
that when you go
to a new dentist, the first
thing they want to do,
they want to give you a
full x-ray of mouth, right?
I don't know, I
don't love that idea
because I'm getting
more radiation.
The other thing is I
have to pay for it.
And so I ask the new dentists,
well, why don't you just
connect to my old dentist?
Because I had my x-rays
there like six months ago.
And just bring the
information there.
It's like oh, I cannot connect.
We're on a different system.
It's like OK, so I decided
before we do the x-ray,
let me go to the old dentist.
And I'll take that
x-ray on the CD, right?
So I found myself-- he
didn't have the CDs.
I actually had to
find that digital CD.
Apparently they have this
thing, medical grade CDs
that cost $20 a pop.
It's like more expensive
than the CD-ROM drive.
And then I bring it.
He burns it on this CD and
I bring to my new doctor.
And he says I cannot take it.
It's like, why not?
He's like well, It's
liability issue.
Maybe somebody tampered
with your pictures.
And then I cannot
operate based on that.
I can't make decisions.
So I was like OK, so I got
the extra dose of radiation.
I had to pay for it
because my insurance didn't
cover more than the one set
of x-rays within six months.
But it just made me think
of how broken the system is
in terms of IT or information
flow in the health care space.
The other little piece
I want to share with you
is as this article was
written by a medical doctor
and also a PhD in economics
by the name of Anupam Jena.
So this gentleman is a
Harvard medical doctor.
The only reason I mention
that he's a PhD in economics
is that we can kind of assume
that he knows how to design
and run an experiment, right?
And the experiment that
he describes in this paper
was very simple.
So he noticed that in the US,
there are 30,000 cardiologists.
And once a year, 70% of them
or 21,000 of those 30,000
go to this conference
that takes a week.
So basically, 70% of arguably
a very important doctor
is out of their hospital,
not seeing patients.
Question is, what happens
to these patients?
Who thinks that the
patients get better?
Who thinks patients get worse?
Well, the data shows that the
patients actually get better.
Mortality goes down when
the doctors are away.
And I'm bringing-- you can
read the details there.
But it's kind of
makes you wonder,
what's going on here, right?
I have some theories.
But what this data suggests
that the decisions that
are made in the context
of health care systems
are not optimized
necessarily for the benefit
of the patients.
And this is not the fault
of any specific doctor.
it's just the incentives
are complex, right?
There is the payer.
There is the provider.
There is a patient.
And sometimes it's not aligned
with the benefit of the people
it should serve.
So as Google, we're trying
to think OK, we're definitely
not coming from a place we
can-- oh, this will solve it,
IT will solve all of this.
But I think our strength is
around organizing information.
So we see our team's
mission is going
to organize the world's
health care information
and help make better
decisions, help our customers
and our partners make better
decisions for health care.
So what we do in
Cloud Healthcare,
we build tools that
help ingest and manage
information for
health care, which
means EHR data, medical imaging
data, genomics data, dictation
data, device data.
And then enable
providers, enable vendors,
enable our partners
and customers
to develop applications on
top of this data like the one
that you saw presented
by IDEXX, by Ben.
So in this short talk,
I want to give you
a little bit of a highlight
of how we are thinking
about our product
development roadmap
and where we are thinking
of going with this mission.
And the one way to slice it
would be in three layers.
So the first layer is
the data platform layer.
And I'll talk a
little bit about this.
But the idea here
is that before you
can use all of these cool tools
like AutoML, like Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, like
big data analytics--
which is, for example,
a tool like BigQuery--
before you can use
all of these tools,
you need to organize your
data in a way that allows you
to use these tools effectively.
Otherwise, as Ben
mentioned, the data comes
and it's kind of a mess.
Sometimes the
metadata is missing.
Sometimes the metadata is wrong.
And it's very
difficult to bring into
a normalized, standard form.
The other piece is once
your data is in the cloud,
what can you do with it?
Like what are the
types of cloud services
that you can use so that you can
focus your application on what
really sets you apart?
And then the last piece
is the actual applications
on top of it.
So this is like three layers
to think about their platform.
And I'll go over in details
about each one of them.
So this is kind
of a high level--
uber high level--
architecture slide
that describes how a
typical medical imaging can
work in the context of a cloud.
So you have some
sort of a device
that produces medical images.
So on the left here,
you see something
that resembles an ultrasound.
Now, the data would be
ingested into the cloud
through a data layer
platform product we have
called Cloud Healthcare API.
And then once the data is in
the cloud, it can be normalized.
It can be visualized using
commercial or open source
viewers.
And it can be used for analysis
or training of AI models.
So if you think about what
happens in a typical--
this is an example from
medical imaging world
because we're talking
about vision--
what happens typically
is the image is acquired,
then it's being
pre-processed, then
it's being presented
to the physician that
makes the decisions, and
then it's being archived.
So these are kind of the
different pieces represented
here.
And the other piece that's
relevant to the data
is our effort around
public data sets.
So if you're a
researcher, then typically
what you're interested in
doing is testing hypotheses.
You might have a
hypothesis of I have
an algorithm idea to detect,
let's say, kidney stones.
I need a way to test this
hypothesis effectively.
And then once I test it, I want
to be able to commercialize it.
I want to be able to integrate
it in a clinical workflow.
So the first piece for
testing hypotheses--
we saw that this creates
a lot of bottleneck.
And a lot of
researchers are doing
a lot of IT work and
sort of doing research.
So what we have done, we
host a set of data sets
that are already public.
We just simplified access
to these data sets.
So if you have, for
example, a research
project around genomics,
or medical imaging, or EHR,
looking into our platform.
You might be able to
find data sets that
would help you
simplify the testing
of the hypotheses process.
Once the data is in the cloud,
what can you do with it?
And it depends really on what do
you want to do with it, right?
At the end of the day, cloud
is a collection of components.
And you can build an
application or solution
that meets your needs.
Some examples I'll bring
from what we see in the field
from talking to
customers or partners.
And on the analytics, two
buckets in this slide.
On the left side you see
that analytics use cases.
On the right side, kind of
machine learning applications.
So BigQuery is our
enterprise data warehouse
tool that can be used
in a very versatile way
to analyze huge
quantities of data,
so petabytes of information.
I'll just give you
one data point.
So BigQuery is the tool that
is used by Google to analyze
search traffic patterns.
So if you think about the
corpus of data behind Search,
this is a tool that can
analyze petabyte scale
without any constraints.
Now, the way we see people
using this in health care
varies a lot by the
nature of the application.
For example, some folks
must have flown into here.
So you must have seen in the
airport when they ask you, hey,
who here has flexibility to
stay and take a longer-- like,
a later flight?
We'll give you, let's say,
a voucher for a hotel.
You can see the city.
Now, this happens
because the airlines,
they don't like to have
empty seats in the airplane
for obvious reasons.
So they double book it.
The problem is you,
sometimes in health care,
find similar resources that are
very high precious commodity--
like for example, an
MRI machine or even
a specific expert, a
specific specialist,
you prefer to overbook and have
maybe the patient wait longer
than having a slot
that is not utilized.
So we see customers that are
using the data that they gather
from different parts of
their health care system
to try and predict no shows.
Or another example I'll
give you is something
called procedure leakage.
Leakage happens when a
patient for example shows up
and let's say they're
about to do a surgery.
It's a planned surgery.
So there is typically
a preoperative imaging.
They will do this
exploratory, make sure that--
as Ben mentioned,
you want to make sure
that the animal, or
the human in this case,
is capable to undergo the
procedure, everything is fine.
But then if you are a large
health care institution,
you see that the
patient chose to do
the imaging in your
institution but then
they chose to do the
surgery somewhere else.
And the way the economics
of health care work,
it actually might be
the imaging procedure
you might be doing at a cost.
But the surgery procedure is the
one that your hospital actually
makes revenue, right?
So that's kind of the
business side of health care.
And then that's a problem
because as a hospital,
you need to better
understand what causes that.
Are your surgeons maybe
providing different service?
Do you need to increase
the cost of your imaging?
This is the type of
business intelligence
that you want to
get from the data
that you're collecting
from your system.
So this is another example of
analysis on large scale data
that you can do.
De-identification.
So that's the thing
I really liked
about working with medical
images data in the animal
spaces, you don't need
to worry about PHI.
So PHI stands for protected
health care information.
In my understanding, there is
no HIPPA for animal pictures.
Which is fun because
you can take selfies
with your patients.
In the human world, it
doesn't work that way.
So you have to be, of course,
very careful what information
is shared, like in
collaborations, for example.
If you have a large
academic medical center,
typically you have the clinical
entity that sees patients,
collects the data.
And then you have the
research part, right?
Like these researchers are
trying to increase the quality,
develop new procedures,
develop new operations,
develop new diagnostic methods.
And they use some of this
data from the clinical side.
But for this research
you have to be
mindful of what data is used.
So this
de-identification process
is very critical to enable
research in institutions.
Now, de-identification
is a hard problem.
I'll give you an example.
Every time I present the
tools that we have around
de-identification, I get the
question, well, can your tool,
for example--
it was a very specific question
that I got until we actually
realized where it came
from-- can your tool detect
the serial number of
a pacemaker in a CT?
It's like whoa,
that's very specific.
It turns out it can, right?
Because when you
have a pacemaker,
it has a unique serial number.
That serial number comes in a
CT image that scans the patient.
And that is used to
identify who that person is.
So that's kind of like, OK,
you didn't think about it.
But the tool actually
does work here.
Now the next question
was, can your tool
detect a name of a patient
written on a grain of rice
in foreign language that was
like, worn, on her necklace.
So this is a real case.
They actually showed
me the picture.
Our tool didn't work
well for this case.
But so didn't the human
operators or any other tools.
So I'm bringing this example
to mention that it's hard.
It's hard to build tools
that are working perfectly.
But these tools are
evolving because
of the advanced technology and
the AI that's kind of embedded
in these schools.
So we're making progress.
And the benefit of
using cloud based tools
is that they evolve without you
having to deploy automatically.
And of course there are
some questions around OK,
so how do you maintain
version controls?
And we have some
thoughts about that we'd
love to share with you as well.
Natural language
processing-- so this
is a huge umbrella of tools.
And it really depends
what you want to do there.
And we have some research
efforts in that space.
And for example, I'll give
you a couple of use cases
just to stimulate thinking.
Imagine a large
health care provider
that reviews thousands
of patients every day.
Now, when a radiologist
writes a report.
They typically
look for the thing
that the patient
was referred for.
Like for example, if the patient
was referred for brain bleed
inspection, the radiologist
is not looking for cancer
because that's what the
physician was telling him, hey,
you should look for this.
And in some cases, since
you already have the person
and you have the information in
front of you, you might alert,
say hey, you need
to look into this.
Because I wasn't looking for
it, but it's there in the data.
So NLP is something
that can be used
as well as image analysis
to try and detect
these incidental findings
or critical findings,
and help organizations
implement certain protocols.
Like for example, maybe you're
looking for brain cancer.
And you want to rule that
out, that doesn't happen.
But on the other
hand, you do see
there is a bleed
that is suspicious
that you want to respond
to within a few minutes
because that might
be life threatening.
So this is an example
where NLP can play a role
to identify what the
radiologist or the doctor
writes in their report,
and start a new process
inside your IT system.
Labeling-- so Ben was
talking about the importance
of labeling.
Anytime you want to train
any kind of AI model,
you need to basically teach it.
Labeling is the way
that you teach AI models
in a supervised learning
kind of environment.
We have a set of tools that
enables you to label data.
And we also have published
some interesting research
on adjudication.
Like if you think
about it, let's say
you want to detect
kidney stones,
just for a simple example.
So one simplistic approach would
be well, have a set of images.
Show these sort of images to
us a radiologist or someone
who can label them effectively.
Basically you can
simplistically think OK, I
show this image to
one doctor, and they
would provide me the labels,
and that's good enough.
In reality, what
happens if you do that,
you bias your model
because you're basically
encoding the brain of that
one particular doctor.
So you need to balance it by
offering several opinions.
And there is a way to do it in
a way that is cost-effective.
The other example is think about
you have a labeling budget.
So let's say you have only 1,000
pictures that you can label.
But you have a pool of 10,000.
Which thousand should you label?
They're not all the same, right?
Some of them might have
more discriminatory powers.
So basically what it
means is that they
have more signal to noise.
So when you're about
to train a model,
you can get more insight
from these thousand
than from the bottom thousand.
On the machine learning side
of things, so AutoML obviously,
this is a kind of a tool
that allows you very quickly
without writing any code to
test out hypotheses to see
how well your model performs.
Some cases, you might be able to
use something that is produced
by AutoML right off the. bat.
In some cases, you use it
as an exploratory tool.
You kind of gain some intuition.
The data scientists
in the audience
would know that you have
lots of different tools.
And depending on the
type of job you have,
you need to choose
the right tool.
What we see in practice is that
customers are experimenting
with different tools.
Like AutoML is kind of
initial exploratory-- super
quick and super easy
to try and understand
the problem and the dimension
in which they should optimize.
And sometimes they
use additional tools,
like Cloud Machine
Learning Engine,
which offers you a little bit
more knobs, more control power
but requires a little bit
more expertise on the machine
learning and data science side.
We are learning that one of the
challenges in the health care
space is that a lot of companies
are building AI algorithms.
And one of the challenges
is how do you--
let's say if you're a
physician, a radiologist
for a medical imaging space--
how do you evaluate
these models?
Somebody says that
they have a model
to detect the thoracic,
or skull, or extremity
versus another model.
How do you compare
their quality?
Right now there is no
standards for that.
Or somebody says
they have a model
to detect lung
nodules for cancer.
Another model is doing the same.
Which one is better?
So we are building
a tool that will
be allowing you to evaluate and
compare these different models
and choose the
right one for you.
A couple of words
on applications.
We are very much embracing
the open source world.
And as Google, we
have a very open DNA.
And we want to enable people
to use the tools that they're
already used too.
And then we have
on the health care
space, and the medical imaging
space, and the vision domain,
we have invested in
integrating some of these tools
with our data back end.
So what that means
is that you can
take one of these
open source viewers
or you can take a several-- we
have several commercial viewers
through partners.
We deliberately chose not
to build our own viewer
because we want to focus on
the data platform and the cloud
services that come with
it, and let the front end
pieces to be driven by the
applications and the market
demand.
Because oftentimes, these things
tend to be highly specific.
For example, I just
learned this morning
about a very
specific application
in the wound management niche--
so a very specific viewer,
very specific workflow tool.
And we want to give the
tools to our partners
to build for these
very specific solutions
because they have the domain
expertise to do that the best.
This is an example of open
source de-identification tools.
Because of the
reasons I mentioned,
de-identification is a
hard problem to solve.
But not only that, it's
a hard problem to--
we have a solution today.
You can try our DID solution.
One question you
might ask is well,
how good is your solution?
Can you give me
some specifications?
The challenge with
that is that in order
to give you specifications, we
need to agree on a data set.
And that data set has to have
PHI in it, protective health
information.
Now for this sensitive data, you
cannot have a publicly-facing
data set with PHI.
So the approach we took is we
integrated existing open source
tools with our data back end.
And we offered these
tools as well as
our own tool to our users,
and customers, and partners
basically to test it
out on your data set.
So the idea is like,
here are three tools.
Two of them are open
source, one of them is ours.
See what works best.
We are learning and practice
that people are actually
trying to do a belt and
suspenders kind of approach.
So they might do
actually all three
in chain because they might
be used to some of these tools
from the past.
Sometimes there is an
issue of compliance
because the open
source tools that
have been approved by their
regulatory group inside,
sometimes our tool takes
longer to get approved.
So they basically
want to increase
the level of confidence
they have in DID solution.
So this is like a
couple of slides just
to show you an example
of what we call a model
browser, a model explorer.
This is just a
mock at this point.
This will be available
around mid-year.
And this is a tool that would
allow you to select an AI
model, to select a data set,
and apply the AI model on a data
set, and be able to
compare or evaluate
or reason about the results.
So for example, think about
you could take an AI model,
you could see that
the data set, and you
can generate an AUC curve
like the ones you've
seen before for AutoML.
We also published a set of
tutorials that teach you
how to essentially how to
build your own AI models on top
of medical imaging data.
And we have one that
focuses on AutoML as a tool.
We have one, if you want a
little bit more flexibility,
focused on Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
Again, the right tool for the
job is the name of the game
here.
So this is the link
where you can find it.
And the example, we
chose to highlight
in this case, very simple and
not really of clinical use.
But it touches through
all the stations
that you would need in order
to develop a real application.
So the example here
uses a public data
set for mammography.
And it basically creates a
classifier for breast density.
You can see screenshots
from AutoML work.
So this basically allows
you to evaluate the results
and tune your model,
you can see hey,
my model is not good enough.
I need to get more data.
A question we often
get is how much
data do I need in order
to train a good model?
And it's an empirical
question, right?
Because if your data,
as I mentioned before,
has a strong signal
to noise ratio,
you might need less data.
But if you keep
feeding it examples
that are the same,
then obviously you
need much more of that.
So the rule of thumb
here-- and Francisco,
maybe keep me honest.
What we're hearing in
the medical imaging space
is that for each
class you're trying
to classify is between
1,000 and 10,000 samples--
kind of a good starting point.
So the advantage
of deep learning
is that it reduces the need for
you to do feature engineering.
But it comes at the expense of
having to produce more data.
In a world where we produce
more data than we ever
knew what to do with before,
I think it can be good news.
The other way we're
trying to optimize it,
how do we help you use
your labeling budget
more effectively?
Once you develop the
model, how do you deploy it
in the clinical workflow?
So this is another piece.
How do you take the output
of your AI predictions
and bring it to the surface
so that your physician can
make use of it?
We have some sample
architectures about that.
Come talk to us if this
is of interest to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]